à votre invité ce matin ce n'est Mabrouk
est le ministre de l'Agriculture
bienvenue sur Europe 1 et bonjour Marc
féno bonjour la première ministre
Elisabeth borne dit à la veille du
Nouvel journée de mobilisation vouloir
mettre de l'apaisement avec les
syndicats et recevoir les groupes de
position au vu de la situation n'avait
pas l'impression que c'est trop peu trop
tard non c'est nitroponie pour essayer
de trouver des chemins d'un dialogue et
d'un apaisement et c'est la volonté qui
a exprimait la première ministre il y a
effectivement dans une interview
et c'est le la responsabilité la
première ministre mais pas seulement de
la première ministre des ministres des
membres de la majorité puis
collectivement il faut qu'on essaie de
retrouver on peut avoir des désaccords
ils ont ils sont et ils ont été très
profonds et ils sont toujours très
profond sur la question de la réforme
des retraites en particulier la question
de l'âge mais dans un pays si on veut
avancer il faut qu'on essaie de trouver
les voies du dialogue oui mais alors
discuter du même sujet parce qu'en somme
ce que dit la première ministre marque
phenos il s'agit d'ouvrir la porte pour
parler de tout de tout sauf des
retraites Laurent Berger vous répondent
maintenant qu'il faut au préalable
mettre la réforme des retraites en pause
et puis discuter
ce que dit Laurent Berger mais oui nous
avons un désaccord deuxièmement on fait
cette réforme des retraites non pas pour
être populaire ça serait d'ailleurs et
parce que nous nous considérons nous
estimons que le système est déjà oui
mais nous en sommes plus là
ce n'est pas parce que nous avons une
conflictualité que nous ne pouvons pas
essayer de dire devant l'opinion que
nous que le sentiment que nous avons
c'est qu'on a besoin de cette réforme et
que dans les termes elle a été posée
elle est posée comme elle devait être
posée voilà c'est je peux pas en dire
comment dirais-je c'est pas une offense
de dire qu'on a une position qu'on
essaie de la défendre et que c'est ça
qui a été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
avant d'être refait tout à l'heure par
Emmanuel Macron et Elisabeth borne
affirme ne plus recourir aux 49-3 hormis
pour les textes budgétaires donc pas de
49-3 pour le texte sur les migrations ou
ce qu'il en restera vous reconnaissez
donc ça a été une erreur non
c'est jamais une erreur d'utiliser les
articles de la Constitution pardon on va
dire comme ça non non
jamais une erreur c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est essayer d'éviter ce genre
d'exercices qui fait que dans la société
dans laquelle on est le 49-3 qui est un
outil qui a été très usité 90% des 49
ans ont été faits hors de cette majorité
donc aujourd'hui contexte le contexte
c'est là que je vais dans votre sens le
contexte qui est un contexte tendu fait
que l'utilisation du 49-3 peut être pris
comme une enfance alors que
factuellement dans l'histoire de la 5e
ça n'en était pas et donc si on peut
essayer de trouver des chemins et des
gars il faut aussi trouver des
partenaires dont on puisse considérer
dont on puisse considérer sur des textes
qu'on se met d'accord ça veut pas dire
qu'on est d'accord sur tout c'est la
question avec qui vous allez discuter on
parle d'élargissement de la majorité ça
sonne comme des débauchages individuels
et pour tout vous dire on dirait qu'il y
a de la fébrilité qui a une forme
d'affolement avant une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation aucune fébrilité la
volonté d'ailleurs je rappelle que nous
l'avons dit depuis le début que la
capacité que nous voulions avoir c'était
celle de pouvoir élargir sur les textes
la majorité ça veut dire qu'on fait
rentrer des gens dans la majorité ça
veut dire que des gens qui sont à
l'extérieur de la majorité qui
d'ailleurs sont dans l'opposition
puisqu'ils ont été du contre une chance
parce que chat est chaude en ce moment
oui on pourrait être aussi chat échaudé
nous-même à vrai dire dans cette affaire
là sur cette affaire de retraite puisque
nous avions un certain nombre
d'engagement mais la vie politique fait
que si à chaque fois on se méfie en
permanence des uns des autres et qu'on
n'est pas capable sur des textes qui
nous paraissent essentiels de se mettre
d'accord à ce moment-là il faut faire
autre chose me semble-t-il donc on a
besoin de travailler avec des gens à
droite à gauche les sociaux-démocrates
les la droite républicaine qui pensent
que sur certains textes on peut se
mettre d'accord vous m'avez bien dit ce
matin pas de fébrilité pas d'affolement
c'est votre état d'esprit c'est l'état
d'esprit de l'exécutif ou c'est une
façon de dire
si vous avez le sentiment que je suis
fébrile ou affolé mais d'abord c'est pas
mon tempérament
peut-être que je cache bien mon jeu et
que je peux être dupliste mais je ne
crois pas la vérité c'est que dans les
moments de tempête on est dans un moment
compliqué hein dans le pays on va dire
le contraire il faut essayer de garder
son calme et essayer de trouver un cap
et puis d'essayer de le faire avec une
tonalité qui soit la tonalité de
l'apaisement avant une nouvelle journée
je le disais acte 10e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites le scénario est-il désormais
écrit à l'avance avec une gangrène des
violences marques la question aussi qui
en sera tenue responsable qui est
responsable du chaos aujourd'hui
ecoutez je trouve que les manifestations
sur les retraites encadré qu'elles ont
été à la fois par les forces de l'ordre
et en cadre aussi par les services
d'ordre des organisations syndicales ce
sont plutôt passées dans de bonnes
configurations donc
il y a pas de grief à faire aux
organisations syndicales qui essaient de
faire les choses en bonheur c'est parce
que vous faites non plus il y a des
éléments extérieurs dans ces
manifestations qui recherchent en
découdre parce que il y a un certain
nombre de gens c'est assez ancien
d'ailleurs qui essaie en permanence de
nourrir par violence la querelle en fait
la violence attise la violence et attise
la querelle et donc on essaye pour ce
qui est du gouvernement par les
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre pour
ce qui est des services d'ordre des
organisations syndicales de faire en
sorte que les manifestations se fassent
dans un cadre qui soit le cadre
classique d'une année épuisée oui
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire quelles
conséquence faut-il craindre quand on a
des forces de l'ordre aussi fatiguées
c'est un appel d'ailleurs qui ont lancé
Gérald Darmanin c'est c'est vrai que
quand vous êtes en permanence harcelé
pendant des heures et que ça se succède
parfois de jour en jour vous pouvez
avoir des sentiments de fatigue et ça
nécessite d'autant plus de vigilance de
la part des forces de l'or mais moi je
leur fais toute confiance je c'est
l'occasion quand même de leur rendre un
grand hommage dans cette période là
cette violence là le harcèlement dont
ils sont parfois les victimes peu peut
mettre de l'attention et donc il leur
appartient mais c'est des gens qui sont
rompus aussi à l'exercice d'essayer de
faire en sorte que les choses se passent
en bonne ordre on vous entend ce matin
Marc fenou vous dites que pour les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites ce sont des manifestations qui
se passent enfin globalement bien
pacifiste avec des éléments radicaux qui
viennent gangrener ces cortèges et
sainte Soline alors comment ça se passe
pour moi c'était avec les éléments
radicaux c'est exactement l'inverse pour
moi c'est des gens qui ont annoncé à
l'avance que leur objectif c'était
d'aller détruire des biens d'aller se
confronter aux forces de l'ordre faut
pas inverser les choses pour le quoi ça
ne solide c'est des éléments radicaux
des éléments des éléments qui nous
vendent au fond du faux pacifisme et de
la résistance civique qui finalement
œuvrent en permanence par la violence et
c'est ce qui s'est passé malheureusement
à Sainte Soline quand bien même
d'ailleurs d'un point de vue préventif
heureusement qu'on a pu saisir toutes
les armes que vous avez vu saisies et
machettes les haches les crayons
mais mais comment des individus dans la
dangerosité donc avéré peuvent-ils comme
ça semer le chaos sans être entre
guillemets stoppés en amont mais ils ont
été beaucoup ils ont été pour un certain
nombre vous voyez bien que quand vous
êtes sur un site aussi large que
celui-là avec des routes partout vous
allez pas mettre sous cloche
complètement mais un territoire c'est
toujours évidemment difficile avec c'est
une propriété privée enfin quand je
parlais d'un territoire d'un point de
vue évidemment c'est une propriété
privée je me permettrais de dire une
chose d'ailleurs quand je vois des
parfois par des parlementaires qui se
promènent au milieu des changes je le
rappelle qui sont sur une propriété
privée et que deux ils détruisent le
bien d'autrui parce que marcher sur du
blé marcher sur du colza marcher sur des
cultures c'est détruire la culture parce
que quand vous avez 10000 personnes sur
10 ou 15 hectares ça fait quand même une
personne tous les 10 mètres
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier lui il parle
d'un trou oui oui il parle d'un trou et
il parle d'une balade dans les champs
mais je pense que ça c'est des gens ça
c'est les c'est des gens qui n'ont pas
le respect des territoires ruraux pas le
respect des des agriculteurs et pas le
respect des gens qui travaillent sur ses
champs c'est pas une balade hein quand
vous prenez dans un champ de blé vous
promenez pas sur sur un terrain de golf
ou sur une pelouse qui est celle de
votre jardin et par ailleurs on est on
est quand même dans un pays y compris
d'ailleurs la révolution ça devrait
rappeler ça quelque chose à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a reconnu le droit de
propriété le droit de propriété c'est
qu'on ne va pas sur la propriote et
d'autrui sans y être autorisé si on va
dans le jardin de Monsieur Mélenchon et
lui dire convaincueillir ses fleurs et
piétiner son jardin je pense qu'il
aimera pas et il appréciera pas et donc
il y a quelque chose d'une heure de la
responsabilité et deuxièmement ces
manifestants pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ils sont venus manifestants
pour moi c'est des et vous commencez
c'est des activistes violents et pour un
certain nombre de gens c'est des gens
qui font de la guérilla
vous aviez même décrit des ultras qui
sont déjà venus d'Italie et autres donc
vous les connaissez un certain nombre
d'entre eux non mais on les connaît pas
toujours c'est indicatif
il y a un certain nombre d'entre eux qui
ont pu être stoppés un certain nombre de
trucs on peut plus s'approcher un
certain nombre d'entre eux qu'on a
désarmés évidemment ils sont ils sont
moins ils sont moins dangereux une fois
qu'on les on leur retire les cailloux
les pierres les boules de pétanque et
tout le reste du matériel qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'amener malheureusement
quand vous êtes sur un volume comme
celui-là vous pouvez pas tout fermer ce
matin de rendre hommage aux gendarmes
qui ont été pris vous avez vu les images
vous avez entendu les sons
certains essaient d'inverser les choses
la vérité 47 gendarmes et aussi un
manifestant qui est encore entre la vie
et la mort c'est une inquiétude pour
vous c'est toujours une inquiétude pour
moi la vie humaine c'est la vie humaine
et la blessure humaine on se rappelle de
ce qui s'était passé pour le barrage de
Sivens et tout avait été arrêté non mais
le on voit bien que c'est un certain
nombre de gens qui ne respectent pas
c'est c'est gentils interviennent sur ce
type d'ouvrage des gens qui ne
respectent pas la vie humaine d'ailleurs
pas plus celle des gendarmes
c'est de ceux avec qui se mêlent qui
sont parfois des gens qui sont plus
pacifiques vous n'auriez pas jusqu'à
dire qu'ils souhaitent quand même qu'il
je pèse absolument mes mots au trébuchet
de ce qu'ils doivent être et je pense
que c'est des gens qui ne font pas
grandcadre tout ça quand vous incendiez
un camion et que il y a peut-être dedans
des gendarmes d'ailleurs dans certains
cas il y avait des gens d'arbres quand
vous lancez des boules de pétanque quand
vous envoyez une fusée de feu d'artifice
une fusée de feu d'artifice si c'est si
c'est mal prise ça décapite ce n'est pas
dénonce dans le Figaro ce matin des
actions de terrorisme d'extrême gauche
terrorisme vous reprenez ce vocabulaire
vous parlez mais
propre vocabulaire et moi je ne je suis
quelqu'un qui dénonce la violence où je
l'ai fait tout le week-end qui défend
les agriculteurs dans ce projet qui a sa
justification plane et entière et par
ailleurs je ne viens pas faire la course
à l'échalote de la comment dirais du mot
le plus fort vous voyez ce que je veux
dire mais ce sont des gens qui
cherchaient à blesser voir plus sur le
terrain et quand vous lancez une fusée
de détresse vous prenez non pas le
risque vous avez un acte qui est un acte
délibéré de violence sur autrui en
particulier en l'occurrence des
gendarmes une enquête a été ouverte
marque feno avec certains qui affirment
violence policière il y a eu des
violences d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
reprenez l'expression est-ce que ça
existe
policière ça veut dire que au fond il y
aura un système organisé
qui ferait que il serait donné des
ordres à la police pour exercer la
violence si quelqu'un trouve que ce qui
s'est passé samedi c'est du registre de
violence qui aurait été exacer à
mauvaise endroit le comme vous le savez
la police et la gendarmerie on le
monopole de la violence légitime
pourquoi parce qu'ils viennent défendre
maintenant les écologistes et la gauche
et la gauche disent qu'ils ont le
monopole de la violence illégitime c'est
le verbe et le blabla et le baratin de
l'extrême gauche et de gens qui se
prétendent écologistes quand vous allez
dans une manifestation avec des gens
enfin regardez les images vous avez des
gens qui étaient en tenue de combat avec
des boucliers avec des techniques qui
sont celles de la technique de la
guérilla faut pas nous raconter que ces
gens-là étaient pacifiques et que ils
avaient l'intentionner comment vous
dites il faut pas nous raconter les
écologistes c'est ce que nous raconte
les gens qui étaient présents sur place
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
je voudrais dire quelque chose de ce
point de vue là parce qu'on dit toujours
et je le fais d'ailleurs je l'ai fait
tout à l'heure sur d'autres sujets il y
avait des manifestants pacifistes et il
y avait à l'intérieur des manifestants
qui étaient
ultra viol ents quand vous allez dans
une manifestation et que vous allez dans
des cortèges où le slogan du cortège
c'est tout brûlé
quand bien même vous ne soyez pas volant
vous vous rendez d'une certaine façon
complice de ceux avec qui vous êtes
droit non on est complice de quoi quand
on n'a pas jeté quand on n'a pas été
fumée
[Musique]
d'une manifestation oui des gens avaient
des actes violents la première chose que
j'essaierai de faire c'est de les
empêcher de le faire ou je partirai si
j'étais pas capable de les maîtriser
mais quand vous restez avec eux d'une
certaine façon vous rendez complices je
parle pas juridiquement mais vous vous
rendez complètement vous dites les
violences policières n'existent pas non
ça n'existe pas il peut y avoir ça a été
dit par le rang de Nunez des des actions
qui relèvent laissons faire les enquêtes
qui relèveraient de choses qui ne sont
pas acceptables d'un point de vue outils
ou d'un point de vue juridique mais ce
que j'ai vu à Sainte-Souline puisque
vous m'interrogez en particulier
là-dessus mais globalement il y a pas de
système organisé il peut y avoir des
gens et qui qui produisent du ce qu'on
appelle du dérapage mais globalement il
faut leur rendre hommage les forces de
l'ordre font leur travail dans des
conditions qui sont extrêmement
difficiles parce que elles contrairement
à ceux qu'elles ont parfois en face
d'eux elles cherchent à préserver la vie
humaine
renommer cette lutte cette lutte en
tibassine est-ce que c'est un un vrai
combat ou est-ce que c'est un prétexte
selon vous
je sais pas si c'est un prêter c'est un
prétexte pour les pour les gens qui
veulent mettre la pagaille et qui sont
forts redevance et par ailleurs c'est un
combat qui est un mauvais combat parce
que c'est un projet je répète sainte
solide on va passer demain protocole en
2018 et un protocole qui a été signé il
y a un protocole qui a été signé y
compris par Madame bateau qui a retiré
sa nature alors je comprends quel est le
des doutes sur les signatures des autres
puisqu'elle elle elle ne respecte pas
ses engagements les agriculteurs eux ils
respectent leurs engagements on va vous
sortir bah c'est Notre Dame des Landes
et vous voyez ce qui s'est passé ensuite
c'est tout à fait inexact sur cette
affaire de sainte Soline c'est réduction
de la pression irrigation pendant la
période d'été on passe de 21 millions de
mètres cubes prélevés l'été à 6 millions
prélevés l'été donc c'est 15 millions de
mètres cubes qui ne seront pas prélevés
l'été les études scientifiques disent
que c'est bon le cadre juridique est
posé mais si on est dans un pays ou
quand tout est levé d'un point de vue
scientifique d'un point de vue juridique
d'un point de vue administratif on vous
explique oui
un mouvement
rien ni personne ni légitime à faire des
stocks d'eau pour une agriculture
intensive et ce mouvement n'est pas prêt
de s'arrêter et bien nous serons face à
ce mouvement parce que ce mouvement
c'est un mouvement antidémocratique
c'est un mouvement qui ne respecte pas
au fond ce que sont les principes d'une
démocratie c'est comme si j'allais voir
mon voisin et dire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec votre permis de construire
parce que les toits sont trop grands
parce que les fenêtres sont comme il
faut et j'ai le droit d'aller détruire
alors que l'ouvrage a été fait dans le
dans les règles de l'art et selon les
règles de l'environnement vous voyez ce
que je veux dire si on ouvre une société
dans lesquelles parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord soi-même on a le droit de le
détruire et on a le droit de remettre en
cause là on a un problème dans les
règles de l'environnement donc la lutte
antibacine n'est pas écologique
enfin moi je considère pas qu'elle soit
écologique on a besoin d'agriculture on
a besoin de produire et on a besoin de
défendre les agriculteurs oui mais
parfois ils sont pas d'accord entre eux
et la Confédération de 70% du
prélèvement en nous est-ce que c'est
écologique ou non la réponse est oui un
bon entendeur merci nous d'avoir été
notre invité bonne journée à vous